- [Voiceover] Let's say that
we have the radical equation,
the square root of three x minus seven
plus the square root
of two x minus one
is equal to zero.
I encourage you to pause the video
and see if you can solve for x
before we work through it together.
Alright, so one thing we could do is
we could try to isolate
each of the radicals
on either side of the equation.
So let's subtract this one from both sides
so I can get it onto the right-hand side,
or a version of it on the right-hand side.
So I'm subtracting it
from the left-hand side
and from the right-hand side.
And so, this is going to get us,
that is going to get us,
on the left-hand side I
just have square root,
these cancel out so I'm just left with
the square root of three x minus seven
is going to be equal to this,
the negative of the square
root of two x minus one.
So now we can square both sides.
And we always have to be
careful when we're doing that
because whether we're
squaring the positive
or the negative square root
here, we're going to get
the same value.
So the solution we might
get might be the version
when we're solving for
the positive square root,
not when we take the negative of it.
So we have to test our
solutions at the end
to make sure that they are actually valid
for our original equation.
But if you square both
sides, on the left-hand side
we're going to get three x minus seven,
and on the right-hand
side, a negative square's
just a positive, and the square root of
two x minus one squared is
going to be two x minus one.
Now let's see, we can
subtract two x from both sides
to get all of our xs on one side,
so I'm trying to get rid of this.
And we can add seven to both sides
because I'm trying to get
rid of the negative seven.
So add seven to both sides.
And we are going to get,
we are going to get
three x minus two x is x,
is equal to negative one plus seven.
x is equal to six.
Now let's verify that this actually works.
So, if we look at our original equation,
the square root of three times six
minus seven, minus seven, needs to plus,
plus, the square root of
two times six minus one,
needs to be equals to zero.
So does this actually work out?
Three times six minus seven.
So this is going to be
the square root of eleven
plus the square root of eleven
needs to be equal to zero,
which clearly is not
going to be equal to zero.
This is two square roots of eleven,
which does not equal zero.
So this does not work, and you might say,
wait, how did this happen?
I did all of this nice, neat algebra,
I didn't make any mistakes,
but I got something that doesn't work.
Well, this right here is
an extraneous solution.
Why is it an extraneous solution?
Because it's actually the
solution to the equation,
it's a solution to the equation,
the square root of three x minus seven
minus the square root of two x minus one
is equal to zero.
And you might say, well,
if it's a solution to that,
if it's the solution to
this thing right over here,
how did I get the answer
while I'm trying to do
algebraic steps there?
Well, the key is when we added,
when we took this on the
right-hand side and squared it,
well it all boiled down to this,
regardless of what starting
point you started with,
due to the exact same thing
you would've gotten to that
say, this point right over here.
So the solution to this ended up
being the solution to this starting point,
versus the one that we
originally started with.
So this one, interestingly,
has no solutions.
And it'd actually be fun to think about
why it has no solutions.
We've shown, to a certain degree,
the only solution you got
by taking reasonable, algebraic steps
is an extraneous one.
It's a solution to a different equation,
that gets, that has a
common intermediate step,
but it's also fun to think about why,
why this right over here is impossible.